[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti del costo che ha il
vostro fu delivery in casa dell'impatto
che ha sulla società sul pianeta delle
cuffiette della apple che vi sono state
consegnate in casa in giornata tutto
questo ha un impatto ha un impatto sul
nostro futuro ma soprattutto sul futuro
dei nostri figli
l'e commerce in boom ogni anno cresce
del 10 del 15 per cento
e così anche il trasporto su gomma ogni
giorno di più noi e le nuove generazioni
ordiniamo quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
ma sempre più anche quello di cui non
abbiamo bisogno
e tutto questo immaginate tutte queste
merci questi insostenibili velocità di
queste merci che girano e che ogni
giorno arrivano nelle nostre case questo
sta generando due enormi fattori
insostenibilità e inquinamento tre sono
le notizie che si sono allineate negli
ultimi giorni sull'orizzonte
dell'energia e dell'ambiente primo le
emissioni di anidride carbonica
continuano a salire
non diminuiscono il pianeta continua a
surriscaldarsi se continuiamo andare in
questa direzione aumenterà di un altro
grado la temperatura del pianeta terra
l'accordo di parigi che abbiamo firmato
nel 2015 che doveva essere un po la cura
la macro cura di questo paziente malato
non sta affatto funzionando va
assolutamente rivisto 2
bisogna utilizzare di più le energie
rinnovabili lo sappiamo tutti
le utilizziamo ma le energie rinnovabili
non stanno crescendo a un tasso di
crescita tale per consentire al nostro
pianeta di essere salvato tre molto
interessante l'accademia di stoccolma ha
consegnato l'ultimo premio dell'economia
a tre giovani ricercatori che sono stati
i primi a mettere in relazione il
rapporto che c'è tra
sviluppo della specie umana tecnologia
il surriscaldamento del pianeta
una cosa è certa non stiamo andando
nella giusta direzione
se continuiamo così bisognerà apportare
delle misure drastiche
pensate che se continuiamo su questa
strada da qui al 2050 le maggiori
nazioni responsabili questo inquinamento
dovranno investire il 2 per cento del
pil
sì esatto il 2 per cento del prodotto
interno lordo di tutto quello che una
nazione produce in misure di eco
sostenibilità totali quindi in tutto ciò
che è transizione energetica andando
verso l'energia pulita ed in tecnologie
abilitanti
in tutto questo quali sono le due
industrie i due settori più responsabili
tutto ciò le attività industriali e
ovviamente i trasporti le due cose vanno
insieme
quindi la logistica ancora una volta è
al centro della dello sviluppo della
razza umana
la logistica in questo momento ha
un'enorme responsabilità sulle emissioni
sull'inquinamento ma anche un'enorme
opportunità e oggi siamo qui a parlare a
parlare di questo le grandi case
costruttrici si sono mosse bene hanno
iniziato a sviluppare dei prodotti negli
ultimi anni che abbandonano i carburanti
tradizionali e vanno verso energie
pulite ma se non abbiamo le giuste leve
dai governi per accelerare questo
ricambio questa transizione dai veicoli
tradizionali che abbiamo oggi in italia
in europa a dei veicoli a energia pulita
ci metterà oltre 33 decenni
insostenibile
dei carburanti che sta dimostrando
veramente di avere delle grandi
grandissime qualità e sta risolvendo un
sacco di problemi e lg o gas naturale
liquido di cui la terra ma soprattutto
l'europa e ricca è un'energia pulita che
si distacca completamente dal mondo del
diesel dal mondo tradizionale e che può
abbassare immediatamente le emissioni di
co2 del 15 per cento e le famose polveri
sottili così nocive soprattutto in città
le abbassa addirittura dell'ottanta per
cento
speriamo che l'unione europea continua
ad accelerare il processo di
decarbonizzazione in europa oggi ci sono
150 stazioni di rifornimento perché il
vero limite è l'infrastruttura quindi
sotto questo punto di vista dobbiamo
accelerate da tantissimo la transizione
verso i veicoli comuni verso questi qui
ma c'è un'altra sfida che i grossi
spedizionieri devono cogliere ma
soprattutto devono affrontare immaginate
se ne oggi le merci che vengono
movimentate sono così tante immaginate
con la nuova generazione dei millenni o
dei digital natives che non andranno
probabilmente proprio più
all'interno dei negozi tradizionali
immaginabile questa insostenibile
velocità di pacchi che devono viaggiare
e allora come facciamo a coniugare
questa domanda
una domanda aggressiva una domanda che
chiede tantissimo come facciamo a
coniugarla con una clientela sempre più
esigente ma soprattutto creando
un'armonia con il pianeta terra nel xxi
secolo
lo facciamo grazie a tre assi nella
manica digitalizzazione che già iniziati
e intelligenza artificiale e block chain
sono termini che in questo periodo sono
un po sulla sulla bocca di tutti che
magari non conosciamo neanche a fondo ma
che da qui ai prossimi due tre anni
muteranno completamente di nuovo un
settore come la logistica che accompagna
l'uomo
dai tempi della costruzione delle
piramidi e che ancora una volta avrà un
impatto molto forte su di noi
di tutte queste tecnologie mi piacerebbe
soffermarmi un attimo su quella più
rilevante che ancora non è tra noi nella
nostra vita di tutti i giorni
la block chain amano temete non è che
starò qui a raccontarvi che cos'è la
black jail come funziona
poi soltanto far emergere un aspetto
l'aspetto principale la sua
incorruttibilità e il fatto di riuscire
a tracciare certificare e verificare
qualsiasi passaggio che va dal
produttore al consumatore
quindi la tecnologia ci darà una grande
grandissima mano perché gli
spedizionieri e non potranno più
esimersi dall'osservare dei percorsi
totali e assoluti di eco sostenibilità a
questo voto entriamo noi in campo però
perché a quel punto neanche noi possiamo
esimerci nel momento in cui facciamo
degli acquisti in quel momento noi
diventiamo attori e la velocità di quel
processo dipende da noi per cui
spegniamo le luci
chiudiamo i rubinetti utilizziamo meno
plastica e chiediamoci sempre da dove e
come arriva quello che acquistiamo
perché il confine tra sostenibile è
insostenibile e anche nella logistica
grazie
[Applauso]